Коли ви дізналися про Майдан, і які емоції це у вас викликало?
Безпосередньо після того, як Мустафа Найєм закликав усіх приходити на Майдан,
я знала, що тепер там знову протестують.
Від самого початку я відчувала, що маю поїхати туди, піти туди, адже я знала,
що йдеться не лише про Україну, а про відносини України з Європою, з Євросоюзом.
Коли ви вперше побували на Майдані?
Через кілька днів після того, як усе почалося, я вже була на Майдані.
Коли розпочався саміт у Вільнюсі, на якому Янукович не підписав асоціацію,
я вирішила, що не поїду з колегами до Вільнюса,
а поїду до Києва і подивлюся на місці, що там, власне, відбувається.
Розкажіть про ваші перші враження від побаченого?
Моє перше враження було таке: я помітила, що все зовсім інакше, ніж під час "помаранчевої революції".
Моє перше враження, яке потім підтвердилося, було таким:
громадяни стали ініціативними та поставили цей Майдан на ноги,
і що все організовано не так, як двітисячі четвертого під час "помаранчевої революції".
Що саме було інакше?
Уся організація була іншою.
Мій перший візит був "неофіційним", я приїхала без делегації.
Я була там як Ребекка Гармс, якій було цікаво, що відбувається.
І дуже добре пригадую, як уперше підійшла до сцени і спитала, чи можу зустрітися з організаторами.
Це була ще перша сцена, ще до того, як вона згоріла.
І люди, з ким я говорила, відповіли, що мають спершу переговорити з керівництвом оргкомітету.
Тоді до сцени підійшов Єгор Соболєв, це був мій перший безпосередній контакт з організаторами.
Під час цієї першої зустрічі ми дуже добре порозумілися.
Коли ви зрозуміли, що ті протести – це серйозно?
Я від самого початку знала: ті, хто це організував, сприймали протести дійсно серйозно.
Тому тієї зими я так прив'язалася до Майдану.
Власне, після першого візиту я приїздила щовихідних
і провела на Майдані Різдвяні канікули разом зі своїм чоловіком.
Спершу довелось його переконувати, але зрештою він також був у повному захваті.
Я дуже добре пригадую, як люди,
тримали один одного під руки, попри наростання насилля з боку Януковича.
Досі дуже чітко пригадую, як обурено українці відреагували
на перше застосування насильства проти протестувальників на Майдані.
Які емоції сповнювали вас, коли студентів, протестувальників на Майдані,
побили в ніч на 30 листопада?
Для мене це був жах, до того ж я ще й шкодувала, що буквально перед цим поїхала звідти.
Коли сталася ця перша ескалація насильства, я саме їхала назад до Брюсселя,
і в глибині душі думала: оце так, я покинула людей у біді, я повинна була залишитися на довше.
Тому частково ще і через це пізніше я їздила до Києва так часто, як тільки могла.
А також намагалася переконати якомога більше колег у Європарламенті в тому,
в тому, наскільки важливо бути на місці й бути свідком того, що там відбувається.
Якби уряд Віктора Януковича підписав угоду про асоціацію, що було б тоді?
Немає сенсу дискутувати про те, що "повинно було б" статися, "було б" чи "могло б".
Натомість сьогодні треба розбиратися вже з тим, що сталося.
Україні та Європейському Союзу важливо не забувати,
що на Майдані люди не тільки протестували за європейську ідею та єдність,
за свободу і демократію, але й що там загинули люди.
Що через запеклу боротьбу українців проти прив'язки до Росії та за європейський шлях,
Росія окупувала Україну та затягнула її в абсолютно жахливу війну.
Важливо постійно усвідомлювати це, аби ми могли спільно продовжувати йти цим складним шляхом,
на який ми ступили, підписавши угоду про асоціацію та візову угоду.
Чи стала Україна за ці п'ять років іншою країною?
Україна стала іншою країною вже взимку тринадцятого-чотирнадцятого років.
І це дуже пов'язано з Януковичем та Володимиром Путіним,
адже українці не хотіли прогинатися під тим насильством, жертвами якого вони стали.
Тієї зими Україна по-новому розпочала те, про що часто кажуть, - консолідація та дорослішання нації.
І в цьому дороги назад уже немає.
Протягом наступних після Майдану років, чи були ви розчаровані тим,
як щось було зроблено, а щось – взагалі не зроблено?
Я маю так багато чого сказати щодо речей, які були зроблені,
які можна було зробити краще. Є багато чого сказати і про регрес...
Кілька найважливіших.
Найважливіші для мене речі - це запуск реформ, які ухвалювалися у Києві, у парламенті та уряді.
Щодо реформи державного управління, далекосяжних реформ,
котрі слугують приборканню системної корупції у багатьох сферах громадського життя.
І також рішення створити антикорупційні органи, зокрема Вищий антикорупційний суд.
Це хороші речі.
Але знову і знову трапляються розчарування.
У неділю марш за права меншин і трансгендерних людей у Києві завершився насильством.
Жахливе вбивство Каті Гандзюк…
Лякає, що відносини між громадянським суспільством і елітами вже не такі хороші,
що насильство проти представників
громадянського суспільства залишається безкарним.
Але якщо дивитися вцілому, то я знаю Україну ще з часів до проголошення незалежності.
І за останні чотири-п'ять років Україна зробила великі кроки до свободи та демократії.
Не варто дивуватися, що цей шлях не подолано за лише одну каденцію парламенту.
Моя власна країна також не була такою, як зараз,
через п'ять років після падіння диктатури чи після того, як Європа прийняла нас у своє співтовариство.
Як ви ставитеся до того, що ЄС робив і якого курсу дотримувався під час Майдану?
І тут були як злети, так і падіння.
Я абсолютно переконана, що угоду про асоціацію справді вибороли люди на Майдані.
Думаю, після Вільнюса у ЄС, у Брюсселі та у інших столицях особливо старіших членів ЄС,
завзяття далі просувати угоду про асоціацію вже не було аж таким великим.
Напевно, це перша міжнародна угода за довгий час, і точно перша торговельна угода,
яку громадяни сусідньої країни вибороли таким чином.
Можна сказати, це продовження того, що відбувалося наприкінці вісімдесятих -
на початку дев'яностих років у НДР та інших країнах Східної Європи. Така моя думка.
І ось цей, так би мовити, процес зцілення та об'єднання на континенті,
який ми спостерігаємо протягом десятилітть, він досі не завершився.
Він і далі триває в Україні, в інших країнах-сусідках Євросоюзу, також на Балканах.
І ми, європейці, повинні й надалі бути відкритими до розширення ЄС.
Ми повинні й надалі бути активними у наших східних країнах-сусідах і на Західних Балканах.
Яке найсильніше враження залишив у вас Майдан?
Чесно, я пережила надзвичайно багато великих та дуже емоційних моментів на Майдані.
Думаю, українці прийняли мене особливим чином протягом цих тижнів
узимку тринадцятого-чотирнадцятого років.
Незабутнім для мене став мій виступ на Майдані у Новорічну ніч.
Незабутньою була і складна ситуація, коли Юлія Тимошенко повернулася до Києва
з колонії у Харкові, і ми з нею були на сцені.
Але точно найважчим моментом була церемонія прощання на Майдані з "Небесною сотнею",
тобто жертвами снайперів "Беркута".
І тоді політики з добрих намірів шукали загальної підтримки того компромісу,
який Штайнмаєр з міністром закордонних справ Франції допомогли досягти з Януковичем.
Та для мене було цілком очевидно, що у тій ситуації, з такими настроями біля сцени,
більше не було жодної можливості для компромісів з Януковичем,
які б дали йому змогу залишитися при владі.
Відколи я це відчула, було ясно, що тепер події будуть розвиватися дуже швидко.
Наступного ранку Янукович зник з Києва.
І не було жодного насильства. Ніхто його не змушував піти.
Він сам усвідомив - після того, як він допустив або ж ініціював стільки насилля,
більше він не міг залишатися на посаді.
Були моменти, коли ви боялися?
Знову й знову мене жахала ескалація насилля.
До того моменту ніколи в своєму житті я не бачила людей, які були настільки мужніми
та виступали за свої ідеї свободи та побудови нормальної європейської країни.
Коли я була на Майдані, я завжди відчувала себе захищеною
моїми українськими друзями, навіть у періоди ескалацій.
Чи згодні ви, що вас називають найбільш проукраїнським німецьким політиком?
Я великий і навіть давній друг України.
Наша дружба розпочалася ще у 88-му році з моєї поїздки у Чорнобильську зону відчуження.
Україна має багато хороших друзів, і я сподіваюся,
що моя дружба допоможе їй йти уперед.